serious trend right now trans-species
ism yeah i know no shoe or yeah i like
to call it a liver I know it sounds like
the devil's language and it is it is
mind you this is a girl who claims that
she was born a cat
no sighs not leg get us a call or get
from to us a lot ma'am I and the fats
know something again fine she insinuates
that her doctor said well just like the
transgender thing well you were born the
wrong gender your birth defect you were
supposed to be a cat listen slippery
meets slope we did the Stephanie the 52
year old guy who claimed it was a
six-year-old girl you can't say that's
absurd it's no more absurd than a man a
winning Woman of the Year that happened
forgot the second I'm not that said they
are poor not often animus or instinct
them it after Marcus you know I get it
for free so Paula hey I have did one
well my son after four time tomorrow
system doesn't do more muscular sure
this is a stupid cat she's not an
antenna cat who uses her words very well
almost let's head out yeah I called my
cousin little poodle yeah no it's not
obvious you're a cat
it's obvious you're a psychopath the
worst part is the reporter is taking
this seriously so the reporter asked
this girl well how would you say like
come here in cat
yum-yum-yum-yum-yum and their fur goes
oh is that correct - and then the camera
pans to her boyfriend yeah oh my god
liberal points like the reporter you're
not gonna call them on that crap here's
what I do okay I go find the reporter I
go how do you say in cat I want to eat a
fish I want you to write it down this
piece of paper
hey hey hey pumpkin pie boyfriend stay
there then look at the boyfriend and say
hey since you speak cat how do you say I
want to eat a fish and if it is not
identical to that page and I lock him up
and I and I put cat ears on them they
treated legitimately and the boyfriend
just by he's just trying to get laid
it's one of those it's just it bothers
me so much because it's this group think
of yes I believe I'm a cat and the other
yes I believe your cat we both speak cat
and he goes along with it because he
wants to get laid
and these two people they might even
believe that they speak cat
they love feelings to supersede all
scientific information available to
humanity it bothers me more than
terrorism because I know what to expect
with terrorism with crazy people and
social justice warriors you never know
what's coming down the pike Isis I would
have to kill the Jews in you and yeah
that's par for the course social justice
warriors the new thing is Turan
speciesism crap I gotta get my lexicon
dude yeah some cult Saracen
uh-huh-huh-huh my defense gave my heart
and they hold the somatic copy effort
some cut watch it it's going to be
mainstream this is it's you're only a
couple years away from it and then come
back and watch me right now saying I
told you so this video subscribe by
clicking my face or the button above or
you oh it's you why don't you have a
girlfriend yet